wir machen einen Sprung zurück und
begleiten das Team nach dem ersten
Scouting und der Entscheidung für eine
Insel auf ihrer Reise nach Panama Wochen
bevor die Teilnehmer anreisen zeigen ihr
erst zusammentreffen und erklären wer
eigentlich dabei ist und welche Aufgaben
sie übernehmen wir wünschen viel Spaß
mit dem ersten Einblicken ins Team
Basecamp und dem wirklichen
Produktionsstart von Seven vs wild
Staffel 2
[Musik]
moin
geil das ist rechtzeitig geschafft hast
[Musik]
also logistisch ist es schon eine
ziemlich Herausforderung am anderen Ende
der Welt so eine Serie machen zu wollen
es ist schon teilweise schwierig mit
Kamera ich Equipment zu reisen aber
diesmal hatten wir Macheten Medikamente
für den erste Scheiben brauchst die
verschreibungspflichtig sind
wir hatten Sauerstoffflaschen wie Bomben
ich weiß gar nicht und die ganze Zeit
einfach viele viele Koffer mit viel viel
Zeug was man eigentlich nicht dabei
haben will und das auch gar keinen
erklären will warum man das unbedingt
braucht zum Glück hatten wir diese ganze
Produktion angemeldet so dass es dann
zumindest hier in Panama relativ easy
war das Zeug durchzubringen also es hat
wieder Erwarten kaum Probleme gemacht wo
man aber auch sagen muss vor allem Paddy
hat sich da wirklich ins Zeug gelegt hat
bei den Airlines angerufen hat gesagt ey
können wir 25 powerbanks transportieren
weil da gibt's dann auch Limits ne
Batterien irgendwie darf man sich endlos
viele mitnehmen und wie ist das mit
Sauerstoffflaschen was müssen wir da
beachten ja es ist schon aufwendig zum
Glück waren wir viele Leute konnten das
irgendwie auch viele Schultern verteilen
aber wir waren sehr sehr glücklich als
dann am Ende alles da war vollzählig die
Koffer durchgezählt alles lebenswichtige
für uns für die Serie war dann da das
war schon cool ja
[Musik]
12 Stunden Flug haben wir hinter uns
gerade großes Zusammentreffen vom ganzen
Team und den wandermut Jungs zumindest
der Teil des Teams der jetzt schon hier
ist jetzt kommen ja die ganzen
Teilnehmer in der kommenden Woche noch
hier an wir sind jetzt in Panama City
von hier geht die Reise weiter in den
Dschungel auf die Insel hier jetzt
erstmal ankommen den Jetlag in
irgendeiner Weise besiegen und dann
geht's weiter dann geht es richtig in
die Planung alles vorbereiten und alle
sind heiß alle sind aufgeregt und keiner
weiß so richtig was uns erwartet
das erste Mal hat sich das Team im
Panama City getroffen und bei wandermut
wir kannten Max und Johannes natürlich
schon aber wir waren natürlich auch
gespannt okay wir sind die anderen alle
drauf und was wäre ich gemerkt haben ist
das Team hat einfach von vom ersten
Moment an richtig cool geweiht du hast
halt gemerkt okay wir haben hier so eine
junge Truppe am Start ne und obwohl wir
eigentlich begrenzte Mittel haben
verglichen mit irgendwelchen riesigen
Produktion
hast du hier einfach ja eine junge
Truppe die die da rausgeht die Bock hat
den Status Quote challengen aber wer ist
das Team überhaupt Johannes und Max
kennt ihr schon das sind die beiden
Mitgründer und Organisatoren von Seven
vs wild die sich von wandermut also Tom
und Martin als Gründern und Paddy als
Projektleitung
organisationsunterstützung geholt haben
um vor Ort alles zu regeln die richtige
Insel zu finden die Helikopter zu
organisieren und vieles mehr für die
Rettung und Versorgung in Notfällen gab
es ein vierköpfiges Team das aus Islam
Thorsten Björn und Clemens Bestand Islam
ist Facharzt für Gefäßchirurgie Notarzt
und vor Ort dafür da wenn jemand über
die medizinische Erstversorgung hinaus
etwas braucht Thorsten den ich schon aus
der zweiten Folge kennt ist Ausbilder
und Rettungsassistent björn ist
ausgebildeter Notfallsanitäter und
vermutlich derjenige im Team der die
meiste notfallerfahrung mitbringt da ist
schon seit Jahren im Job arbeitet und
last but not least Clemens
Rettungssanitäter und Feuerwehrmann wie
genau dieses Team agiert und wie es in
dem Notfall abläuft erfahrt ihr in den
nächsten Folgen an einem realen Beispiel
vergesst also nicht den Kanal kostenlos
zu abonnieren um diese und alle weiteren
Folgen nicht zu verpassen natürlich muss
neben der medizinischen Versorgung und
der Organisation aber auch gefilmt
fotografiert animiert und geschnitten
werden Johannes und Max kommen hier auch
wieder ins Spiel sind Produktionsleiter
Filmen auch selber machen Regie und
schneiden Pat ist drohnenpilot Cutter
und die OP was director of photography
heißt und so viel bedeutet wie er ist
der entscheidende Mann an der Kamera für
das gesamte Projekt und ich Dave bin
angereist um für euch dieses Geheimnis
zu produzieren und zu filmen bin aber
auch irgendwie dann im Team für die
Hauptserie gelandet und habe dort auch
mitgefilmt Rico steckt hinter allen
Animationen die ihr in der Hauptserie
seht und erst vor Ort
hauptverantwortlich für Fotos aus denen
ein unglaublicher Bildband mit
exklusiven Material Interviews der
Teilnehmer und des Teams und weiteren
zeitfacts entstanden ist darüber hinaus
gibt es Fotokalender Poster und
verschiedenste Bundles also für jeden
etwas dabei und vermutlich das perfekte
Weihnachtsgeschenk für jeden seven vs
wild verrückten Check die Produkte über
den ersten Link in der Videobeschreibung
ab und viel Spaß mit den Fotos natürlich
braucht man aber auch Unterstützung der
einheimischen nimm du stellvertretend
für alle vier Boots Kapitäne Roberto
unser Helikopter Pilot der genau wie die
Bootsführer neben dem Scouting auch die
ganze Zeit in Bereitschaft für eine
potentielle Rettung zur Verfügung
standen Roberto heißt eigentlich nicht
wirklich Roberto mit den Helikopter
Piloten gab es allerdings während und
nach der Produktion so Riesenprobleme
dass wir Ihren Namen ändern mussten mehr
dazu in den nächsten Folgen natürlich
hatten wir aber auch einige helfende
Hände dabei Manu als finance Rita als
Arzthelferin und Julian hinter der
Kamera jeder hat Aufgaben erledigt die
über den eigentlichen Tätigkeitsbereich
hinausgegangen sind und nur so konnten
wir dieses riesen Projekt in dieser Form
umsetzen also hier ein riesen Dankeschön
an jeden Einzelnen aus dem Team für ihre
Arbeit und die unheimlich aufregende und
lustige Zeit vielen Dank
[Musik]
bei so einer Produktion mit so vielen
Leuten ist es natürlich extrem wichtig
dass jeder weiß zu jedem Zeitpunkt wann
er wo gebraucht wird wann ist wer wo vor
allem wenn man das Team splitten muss
also ein Teil des Teams hier auf sein
José und ein Teil im Panama City oder
vielleicht sogar noch in Deutschland
dass jeder trotzdem weiß okay wann muss
sie am Flughafen sein wann muss ich die
Fähre betreten wann muss ich mir ins
Taxi setzen wann muss ich was essen da
muss ich scheißen so das muss eigentlich
alles klar sein weil sonst hast du
irgendwann das Problem dass irgendjemand
irgendwo ist wohl nicht sein soll und
dann fehlt da irgendwo deswegen ist das
sehr sehr wichtig so ein Ablaufplan zu
machen den haben wir gemeinsam mit
wandermut erstellt weil die ja
größtenteils für die Logistik
verantwortlich waren ja und das hat dann
dazu geführt dass der Hauptteil des
Teams drei Tage nach wandermut hier
eingetroffen ist und dann ging die
finalen Vorbereitung hier in Panama los
wir haben sehr sehr Bock auf die
nächsten Tage es werden anstrengende
Tage es werden aber auch keine Tage und
ich bin mir ziemlich sicher dass wir das
alle zusammen ziemlich geil machen
werden für alles was Orga Logistik
angeht sind hier die wandermut Leute
wir werden es nicht übertreiben weil
wahrscheinlich 70 80 Prozent dafür
gesorgt haben dass das Ganze überhaupt
läuft wie es läuft läuft
von von uns erstmal ein ganz ganz
herzliches Hallo damals war es noch so
die Idee der Vision man könnte das hier
in Panama machen und allein in diese
Insel die er dann morgen sehen werdet
das ist einfach schon krasser shot wenn
ihr wir werden ja das Glück haben mit
einem Flugzeug hinzufliegen und wenn ihr
einfach schon seht dieser Urwald dieser
Dschungel auf euch zukommen das hat sich
das richtige Jurassic feelings äh
Jurassic Park Feeling dann werdet ihr
sehen warum es diese Insel geworden ist
für uns ist einfach krass weil wir jetzt
seit 6 Monaten darauf hinarbeiten wir
haben gesehen was ihr einfach vorher
schon geschafft habt jetzt sind wir
einen Punkt wo die Planung so bei 90 95%
abgeschlossen ist jetzt noch die letzten
kleinen Hindernisse oder die letzten
kleinen challenges die wir hier meistern
müssen aber
das ist ist wirklich nur das letzte
bisschen damit dann haben wir das auch
jetzt erstmal wichtig anzukommen den
Ausblick zu genießen was auf uns zukommt
denn das wird der Hammer werden das wird
richtig gut werden und ich gebe einmal
noch an Paddy bevor wir anstoßen an den
Ablaufplan für morgen und dann stoßer
final an und dann geht's ab ins Bett
ganz kurz Morgen und den nächsten Tagen
ich würde mich kurz fassen weil ihr seid
alle müde im Großen und Ganzen und
erwarten jetzt ein paar spannende Tage
auf der Insel wir werden auf jeden Fall
noch eine intensive Zeit haben bevor es
losgeht es wird sicher noch das eine
oder andere Last Minute Drama kommen
aber es wäre ja auch langweilig sonst
und genauso auch dass das ein
hammerprojekt wird
[Musik]
so wir haben jetzt gerade alles gepackt
man sieht hier das Auto ist wirklich bis
zum Rand vollgepackt Tetris für
Fortgeschrittene und wir sind jetzt
gerade auf dem Weg zum Albbruck
Flughafen dort hatten wir alles in die
Karo Flugzeuge und dann fingen wir nach
Israel lässt die Anspannung so ein
bisschen nach war gestern die Anspannung
jetzt nicht da
[Musik]
okay es geht los mit zwei
Propellermaschine jetzt hier vom
Festland auf die Insel winzige Maschine
insgesamt zwei Flugzeuge ein Cargo
Flugzeug noch es wird ein Fest
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wir sitzen im Flieger 15 Leute rechts
unter unserem Wal gesehen als bemerken
jetzt schon dass wir wirklich in ein
Gebiet vordringen was absolut
unangetastete Natur ist nur wenige von
uns die im Flugzeug sitzen waren schon
mal auf der Insel für den Großteil von
uns ist das allererste Mal und wir
können jetzt schon vor den Teilnehmern
sehen was sie so ein bisschen erwarten
wird also hier ist wirklich Dschungel
wirklich Natur es ist unglaublich also
ich weiß gar nicht was ich sagen soll
[Musik]
was für ein Erlebnis mit dem kompletten
Team hier auf die tropische Insel
winziger Flughafen winzige Landebahn
Wale auf dem Flug gesehen also das was
wir jetzt schon von der Insel gesehen
haben bedeutet eine absolute Tortur für
die nächsten 7 Tage und die sieben
Teilnehmer das sieht wirklich Menschen
unfreundlich aus für Leute die keine
Ahnung vom Dschungel haben
[Musik]
über eine der wenigen Straßen wenn man
sie Straßen nennen kann ging es dann
fürs gesamte Team Richtung passieren
darf die für die nächsten Tage und
wochenunterkunft fürs gesamte Team sein
sollte
[Musik]
einer der schönsten Orte die ich je
gesehen habe
[Musik]
viel versprochen
einfach
ist einfach der schönste Ort der Erde
hier ach du scheiße also vor uns absolut
unglaubliche atemberaubende Küste Palmen
mit Kokosnüssen weißer Sandstrand es
sieht unglaublich aus und wir wissen
dass wir das in den nächsten 7 Tagen
natürlich super entspannt genießen
können während die anderen vermutlich zu
kämpfen und zu leiden haben
[Musik]
erster Eindruck der Hammer so wir müssen
alle schwimmen gehen instant
wir müssen runter ins Meer natürlich
sind wir nicht zum Spaß extra früher
angereist es gibt eine Menge zu
organisieren es gibt verschiedene Teams
die sich alle in ihrem Bereichen
organisieren müssen das medical team
muss alle Medikamente vernünftig
sortieren alle Eventualitäten beseitigen
es muss richtig viel organisiert werden
natürlich müssen aber auch die Spots
abgecheckt werden und es muss
entschieden werden welches Bots
tatsächlich gewählt werden
glücklicherweise waren Max und Johannes
früher schon mal hier und haben schon
eine grobe Auswahl getroffen wer genau
aber welchen Spot bekommt darum müssen
wir uns jetzt kümmern wir fahren mit dem
Boot raus um die komplette Insel und
machen uns davon mal genaueres Bild und
wählen mit professioneller Unterstützung
aus wer wo ausgesetzt wird
[Musik]
hinter uns krachen gerade die Wellen an
die Felsen viel stärker als ich selber
gedacht hätte aber klar wir sind im
Pazifik unterwegs hier hat es ordentlich
Welle ziemlich problematisch hier
irgendwen ins Wasser zu schmeißen
glücklicherweise ist aber keine Flut
während wir die Teilnehmer aussetzen
sondern genau zwischen Ebbe und Flut
also das sollte das Wasser sich ziemlich
entspannen so ist das wirklich
problematisch also wenn man kein guter
Schwimmer ist wenn man keine Flossen
dabei hat dann ist es eigentlich
nicht möglich hier irgendwen auszusetzen
würde ich jetzt als absoluter Laie sagen
zum Glück haben wir Profis dabei die uns
dabei helfen können das ein bisschen
besser auszuloten die werde ich gleich
auch noch mal alle zu Wort kommen lassen
aber das sieht schon wirklich heftig aus
das ist noch mal eine ganz andere Nummer
als Schweden letztes Jahr
da habe ich übrigens auch schon verkackt
also da hat sich mal reingebracht
also wirklich unglaublich wir sind
mitten in der Natur angekommen das hier
ist untouched und das merkt man sehr
Großteil von uns hat gerade zum ersten
Mal einen Wal aus wenigen Metern
Entfernung gesehen hier ist leben hier
geht's richtig ab und wir sind jetzt zu
Gast wir werden uns natürlich
dementsprechend verhalten aber wirklich
ein einmaliges Erlebnis das ist der
absolute Oberhammer
[Musik]
der erste Spot hier direkt hinter uns
etwas problematisch der Profi der
einheimische hat uns gerade direkt
gesagt dass mit dem Aussetzen durch
Strömung hier wirklich schwierig werden
könnte dass die Bedingungen nachmittags
schon deutlich besser sind und sie sind
schon nicht gut
gerade bei unerfahrenen Teilnehmern ist
das eigentlich nicht machbar wir fahren
erstmal weiter zu anderen Spots und
schauen ob wir was Besseres finden sieht
idyllisch aus aber wenn es so gefährlich
ist dass wir die Rettungsaktion direkt
nach dem Aussetzen starten müssen dann
hat keiner was davon und es ist so
gefährlich dass er uns gerade sogar
davon abrät selber hier an Land zu gehen
also das ist wirklich kein Spaß
also mich hat jetzt schon erwischt ich
bin jetzt seekrank geworden hier bei den
Wellen also teilweise was ist das drei
vier Meter Wellen glaube hier hat man
Spaß wenn man ein bisschen schwimmen
geht
und so brechen wir auf am Tag zwei
weitere Scouting alle Plätze müssen
gesichtet werden gestern war leider
nicht so viel Kram dabei dass wir sagen
könnten das hätte gereicht heute geht's
an die etwas vielversprechenderen Spots
nicht alleine sondern mit dem gesamten
medical team wir sind mit zwei Booten
dieses Mal unterwegs also noch ein
größeres Team damit wir dort auch
checken können alle Bescheid wissen und
bin gespannt was uns erwartet wir sind
heute noch mal raus um alles Spots zu
checken wir haben insgesamt 14 Stück und
wir werden alle prüfen auf die survival
Ressourcen wir werden schauen ob es tief
genug ist um da den Helikopter zu machen
und wir werden dann halt noch schauen
wie gut die geeignet sind also machen
sich gut auf Kamera und ich hoffe dass
wir am Ende des Tages sieben Finale
Spots haben für die Teilnehmer
[Musik]
also der Spot ist halt ein kompletter
Jackpot weil man hat einfach ein
Süßwasserquelle direkt am aufsetzen
bekommt
das ist ein sehr geiler Scott auf jeden
Fall mit mega viel Ressourcen mega viel
Müll der aber geil zum Kraft ist für die
Teilnehmer auch wieder ein sehr geiler
squad
wir haben jetzt gerade noch zufällig
Sport bekommen und der ist ein absolutes
Charakter
sogar zwei paar Schuhe Nikes
so Vorletzter Sport sehr raft sehr große
Felsen hier im Wasser teilweise auch
Kokosnüsse sehr hoch okay da vorne wurde
gerade gesagt geht's nach deutlich
geiler weiter
ja komplett epischer Squad würde ich
sagen ne zum Abschluss der
Erkundungstour haben wir uns hier ein
absolutes Schmankerl aufgehoben
wahrscheinlich mit der schwierigste Spot
eine Flussmündung die ins Meer reinführt
also wirklich absolutes Paradies für die
Salzwasserkrokodile die es hier gibt ähm
es sieht jetzt schon beängstigend aus
und die Sonne ist nicht mal
untergegangen also ich habe nicht mal
Bock hier aus dem Boot herauszusteigen
da könnte man abgesetzt werden
theoretisch
treffen natürlich keine Ahnung davon
aber ich weiß dass die Dinger beißen
können dass Sie hier sind dieser Spot
wenn den jemand bekommt ist kein Witz
Flug hin Wale erste Bootsfahrt Wale
heute das Ding Race Wale
Salzwasserkrokodil es ist unglaublich
wirklich
ein Tag fürs Making Off auf gar keinen
Fall
nach fünf weiteren unheimlich
anstrengenden scouting-tagen an denen
wir mehrere Stunden auf dem Boot
verbrachten um drohnenshots von allen
Spots in allen Gezeiten und Tageszeiten
sammeln zu können jeden Sport einzeln
abgetaucht sind unglaubliche Begegnungen
mit wilden Tieren hatten und die
verrücktesten Naturspektakel erleben
durften konnte sich endlich final für
Spots entschieden werden am letzten Tag
des gautings auf dem Weg zurück zur
Hacienda sollte uns aber eine ziemlich
besorgniserregende Nachricht vom Team
aus dem Basecamp erreichen
[Musik]